hello everyone
welcome to a special treyarch studio
broadcast i'm john raphas
and the launch of season four feels like
it was just yesterday
now we brace ourselves for the arrival
of a mid-season update and it is
filled with plenty of new content
treyarch's newest
long-anticipated zombies map arrives
this week and we figured
it'd be appropriate to kick things off
with the zombies team
we caught up with them earlier and this
is what they had to share
[Music]
hello everyone it's nice to be back i
think the
last broadcast that kevin and i did
a lot of things got bleeped out
we are very excited about murder toten
which is going to be set
in war-torn berlin it's kind of the
connection point between east and west
it's kind of
the best place for a zombies outbreak
what better
place to battle the undead than a dark
stormy night you know everything's wet
there's lights and fires reflecting off
the puddles of water
really sets a really eerie and moody
tone so in terms of where we're at in
the story at the end of outbreak's last
main quest
the requiem strike team were captured by
omega
everyone fell for our fake out with the
x-fil
obviously the tragic shooting down of
raptor one
i'm happy to say raptor one is not dead
for this map he is very much going to be
the princess
in the castle because if you don't do
what omega tell you to do
and complete their objectives rather
than the usual
objectives you're given by our usual
requiem crew they're going to kill them
so i hope that means that you're all
suitably motivated
to do the right thing players will
experience a new perk which is mule kick
mule kick this game has really embraced
its theme of
excess so it's just literally various
guns
along the sides of it and every time you
purchase the perk it has a chance to
just
shoot bullets in every direction as you
upgrade the perk you'll eventually
access
all zombies drop ammo and then you'll be
able to craft
twice the amount of equipment for the
same cost finally you'll be able to
actually have a chance to not even
consume equipment when you use it
the new wonder weapon for it's called
the crbrs
or you can just call it the cerberus i'm
really excited about this one as it
takes me back to
my days in the arcades playing
shoot-em-ups where you
you know get power-ups for your ship and
change the way your weapon functions
the base version has a little companion
sphere whenever you fire it fires
when you kill enemies it will drop a mod
kit
and then it becomes a different weapon
so the first mod kit is the diffuser the
diffuser
has a spreadshot of five shots at once
blazer fires a beam of concentrated
energy
now the swarm will fire a salvo of
miniature missiles that have a bunch of
explosions
so another thing we weren't allowed to
talk about last time
was the introduction of a new character
called klaus
who is very much an ai helper through
this level
who has his own backstory and also i
think some of the funniest lines that
we've had
and american-made roblox is a german
personality that was what kevin and i
were laughing about last time
class is going to be a very important
member of our team
because there are things that only he
can deal with do this
do that story of my life we're also
introducing a new tactical equipment
called the lt-53 chasm what it does is
it creates a black hole when it's tossed
that allows you to jump in and escape
but the happy side effect of this thing
is that it actually pulls in all the
zombies
and they go poof too one of the new
enemies
in our duton is the tormentor tormentor
is a very fast suicide charge enemy
the newest enemy to join our ranks is
the disciple
he's all about being in the space making
the zombies nearby stronger
and trying to evade the player he floats
above the the zombies so he stands out
which the map really takes advantage of
because he can be on top of
tanks or vehicles another enemy that
shows up in bauer de toten
is the krasny soldier now this guy is
really well suited to
the ups and downs of this map i think
players are really gonna
notice the verticality players are gonna
be able to move from
the rooftops all the way down to the go
station
down there are these like flaming trains
that are full of zombies
so you gotta watch out up on the surface
we'll have zip lines that'll
take players up and down between the
streets and the roofs pretty quickly
as with every new round based map we
also introduced new challenges unique to
the map really tied into the intel that
we're delivering i doubt you realize
what she has done we also have another
dark ops challenge
tied with the main quest a new feature
we're adding to all round based maps
is dynamic wall buys every five rounds
every wall buy has a chance to
increase its rear all the way up to
legendary when you get to really high
rounds all the wall buys will
eventually become legendary we are going
to be bringing some
new health changes to zombies so what we
did
was we lowered the health cap across the
board you're gonna be able to
effectively kill zombies
at the highest rounds where it feels
good we're also adding
weaver as an operator this is weaver
when he recently lost his eye and this
is the version of weaver that you're
going to be able to play as
he certainly appreciated not just being
sat behind his desk
watching other people do all the the fun
stuff
we're going to be bringing rush to
onslaught and an entirely new limited
time mode called
onslaught accelerated which is going to
be the most frantic version
of the mode we've seen the orb will
constantly
be moving and never stopping the orb
waits for nobody so unless you're
killing them efficiently
you're really going to get overwhelmed
fast but to add a little
something to it as you kill zombies the
ore moves even faster
we all know that people have been
eagerly anticipating a new round-based
map for quite a while and we've been
working
very very very hard on it and we really
believe that when people
finish the main quest in this they're
going to be shocked
and they're also going to be very
excited about where we go next
while zombies serves up quite the undead
update
multiplayer is also bringing the heat
with a number of updates
on the map front treyarch is excited to
bring a black ops 2 classic into the mix
rush and its epic paintball theme is
coming back
for a new generation in this 6v6 map
players will enjoy a variety of lanes
and engagements with something for
everyone
can't get enough of this classic we've
got good news for you
players will also have the opportunity
to jump into rush 24 7.
to keep the theme going players can also
enjoy the new paintball mosh pit
available in 656 with paintball impact
visuals and sounds
later in the season capture the flag is
a classic mode that returns to the fray
one of the original multiplayer modes
from the early days of call of duty
is back for players who fell in love
with die hardpoint during the 80s summer
action event
we're upping the ante with cranked mosh
pit
this new playlist will include cranked
team deathmatch and cranked kill
confirmed for the first time
there are two new weapons that we'll see
as well the ots9 smg
at mid-season launch and the brutal mace
melee weapon coming later in the season
also in the multiplayer mix the team is
rolling out new
league play rewards which will feature
weapon blueprints added for achieving
milestones
as well as new cdl themed weapon charms
new emblems
stickers and xp bonuses for hitting win
milestones all the way to 100 players
will also find new weapon blueprints
joining the prestige shop for the first
time
including the new dark horse smg and
the confrontation assault rifle there
are a few surprises in store for fans of
warzone as well
with this mid-season update warzone and
the team at raven serve up a new game
mode
a team-based ltm that's focused on
escorting icbms
what could possibly go wrong exactly and
that's where it gets fun
payload is a team-based ltm that's
focused on escorting
icbms dividing players into two teams
attackers and defenders the attacker's
objective is to deliver the payload to
the final destination by pushing it
and the defender's objective is to stop
the attackers from pushing the payload
to its final destination
the clock is ticking however a time
limit will be imposed so get to it
warzone also delivers a new kill streak
the sentry gun
this latest kill streak for warzone
operates as you'd expect from
multiplayer
scanning for targets in the radius in
front while it's deployed
it is an extremely rare loot drop in
game
players will also get to experience a
special global event in season
where contraband contracts automatically
spawn after players complete two regular
contracts
these contracts will provide the
opportunity to earn plenty of weapon
blueprints from your prior seasons
so keep a lookout later in the season
finally
players have the opportunity to gift the
battle pass
battle pass bundle and store bundles to
friends in warzone
starting with season four reloaded in
closing
we'd like to thank the zombies team for
stopping by giving us their time
giving us the download on all things
malware dear token
thank you to our crew tommy ben foxy and
thank
you for tuning in we hope you enjoy
everything that this update has to offer
we hope to see you online
that's me alluding to max's but
you can't use the bit that i just said i
want to spoil it